dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on affair earlier we
had an episode about open e is
absolutely amazing algorithm that
mastered dota 2 a competitive online
battler II in a game and managed to beat
some of the best players in the world in
a relatively limited 1vs1 game mode
while the full 5 versus 5 version of
this learning algorithm is still in the
works
scientists at open AI experimented with
some self play in other games and have
found some remarkable results you can
see here that most of these amusing
experiments take place in a made-up 3d
game with simulated physics for instance
performing well with these humanoid
creatures means controlling 17 actuated
joints properly these agents use a
reinforcement learning algorithm to
maximize a reward for instance a sumo
warrior gets a thousand points for
pushing their opponent out of the ring
the first interesting thing is that a
learning curriculum was used which means
that the algorithm was allowed to
explore on their own by relaxing the
strict scores that are given only when
winning this is combined with the fact
that these agents play against
themselves led to some remarkable
emergent behaviors here you can see with
the score how much of the difference
this curriculum makes and you also see
that whenever a plot is symmetric that
means that they are zero-sum games so if
one agent wins a given number of points
the other loses the same amount the
south' play part is also particularly
interesting as many agents are being
trained in parallel at the same time and
if we are talking about one versus one
games we have to create some useful
logic to decide who to pair with whom it
seems that training against an older
version of a previously challenged
opponent was the best strategy this
makes sense because they are running a
similar algorithm and for self play this
means that the algorithm is asked to
defeat an older version of itself if it
can reliably do that it will lead to a
smooth and predictable learning process
it is kind of incredible to think about
the fact that we have a virtual world
with a bunch of simulated learning
creatures and we are omnipotent beings
trying to craft the optimal learning
experience for them the perks of being
researcher in machine learning and we
are even being paid for this isn't this
incredible
there are so many interesting results
here and so much to talk about
for instance we haven't even talked
about transfer learning where these
creatures learn to generalize their
knowledge learned from previous tasks to
tackle new challenges more efficiently
make sure to have a look at the paper
and the source code is available for
everyone free of charge if you're one of
those fellow thinkers you'll be more
than happy to look into the video
description if you wish to hear more
about transfer learning subscribe and
turn on notifications because the next
episode is going to be about some really
cool results in this area thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time
[Music]